so you're more of a classical liberal
you're not you're not a shout people
down or call them you don't believe me
to be a Nazi correct
dad I'm chucking this is very rare like
I would rather have a beer with you than
probably like the 90 percenter my
conservative friends because I think it
we'd actually learn something from each
other absolutely okay time for a bonus
edition of changed my mind in our latest
installment we pushed back against the
increasingly accepted narratives that
Thanksgiving is a racist holiday and it
really did lead to some great productive
rational conversations that you can
watch by clicking the video above which
reminds me with all of these changed my
mind videos I haven't taken the time to
ask you have you used these techniques
the Socratic method and what kind of
results have you seen have you had any
conversations with people that may be
surprised you were productive were
rational let me know in the comments
below as always however we did have
those who were less enthused about the
mere idea of us being there be thankful
and everything but like the origins of
Thanksgiving let us sell something to
celebrate
more or less
slavery I think you people have worms in
your brains elaborate worms are eating
them so you don't think this is a cancer
and parasitic to society wait wait wait
wait white people white people are yes I
do and it is why people are cancer it's
sad when they don't sit down you never
know who you miss you never know who you
miss which is why I wanted to set this
conversation with Phil a self-identified
classical liberal aside as its own video
to show you just how great a
conversation reaching across the aisle
can be was your name sir Phil Phil nice
to meet you nice to meet you all right I
don't know if you're familiar where the
Hat will where the hell you will I will
give it up for Phil where in the Hat you
got a big noggin I have a big head to it
yeah do you have a hard time finding
Hanks yeah I was very rough as a child
it's one size fits all [ __ ] [ __ ]
I had the same thing I have paired
goosebumps boxers as a kid maybe you're
too young for the book came with a
parent glow-in-the-dark boxers yeah yeah
I was a fat little kid it wasn't one
sighs photography oh so huge pecker so
now it's a real problem
yeah kill okay Stephen sorry I single
syllable names are hard for me so I
don't know if you're familiar at all
with the show we do I'm some with some
okay so today we've been talking about
this I'm sure you obviously heard some
the controversy has lumbus day and a lot
of people want to remove Thanksgiving of
course from even the list of nationally
recognized holidays actually believe
it's racist I do not believe that's the
case I think Thanksgiving is a wonderful
holiday I think it's arguably the most
inclusive holiday that we have God has
done me good will do me good god bless
it
that's an ebony nurse cruise line from
his little nephew there ah and happy
Thanksgiving to you before we get any
change on your mind what do you most
thankful for I am probably most like
both my wonderful mother she did a lot
for me growing up yeah and she was a
single single mother for a long time you
know she got a wife so yeah she's a
lesbian
yeah but uh you know she definitely did
well for she a lesbian when you were
young
she was actually buy so she married my
father okay then they got divorced so
then she found herself a very wonderful
wife and did she always know she was
lesbian no she did not
so she found relations by so okay she
always know she was bi no she did not
so so that was it I'm only curious
because was after the divorce where she
hasn't realized it was fermented and I
was I knew a guy who was married and
then she left and she became a lesbian
you know he was devastated it was hard I
know because you know there's a lot of
sort of internalization yeah but he
thought like what did I do wrong
exactly yeah just turned out she was a
lesbian yeah yeah yeah you didn't know
anything okay
I'm sorry we've gone off on it what
happens I've been sitting down for hours
I bet it and this at my hands a little
too tight again because of the one size
fits all so what do you disagree with
here on the premises try to agree that
it isn't racist but I feel that
Thanksgiving is very much more ignorant
and I would say is an inclusive though
we tried to be inclusive okay that's my
side of the argument how so first off
I'd like to say that uh of course this
is all around you know 1617 1621 but
Thanksgiving actually didn't become a
national holiday until about 1863 from
Abraham Lincoln really but this comes
very much after say the 1830 the Indian
Removal Act and basically our deep
history with Native Americans and of
course that we they've had their you
know the wars and the conflicts between
them and we've also had there are
conflicts with them rather than so I
just feel that when we like gloss over
that kind of stuff when we just make it
a national holiday years afterward and
then what do I think of when I go back
to my I say my elementary school days I
just remember being in the cafeteria
where half the class is dressed up as
Pilgrims and half of us are dressed up
the Native Americans and we don't really
learn anything about it we just see you
we sort of just hold hands and sing
Kumbaya right and then it's just I just
feel that it's known it may not be
racist the I'd say that the background
that comes with it is very much
unexplained especially at an early age
and that I shouldn't I say that it
shouldn't be canceled as a national
holiday but I feel that the awareness of
the people is very low than what it
should probably should be okay um I
actually appreciate that now see I was
raised in Canada and got Canadian
Thanksgiving a silly
it was in October but I'm sure as you
know it seems like your history buff you
remember George Washington wanted to
recognize the holidays October 4th I'm
Jefferson didn't want to celebrate it
and when you said actually that you were
going to go to the fact that it wasn't
an actual holiday I thought you were
going to go to what's often taught in
schools you know the the winthorpe
letters
where was the peak was and people trying
to conflate that sometimes and say well
look he had things like well that was
Thanksgiving for victory in battle
wasn't it all the same so we both do
agree that it was the 1621
initial feast commercial and then
Abraham Lincoln was recognizing that as
a symbol of unity right yes yes okay so
we both agree on that and I want to be
very clear I don't disagree anything
else that you presented prefers the
Indians removal but Native American
anyway one thing this is a good example
I can't if I say my favorite Richard
Pryor album is I can't say it I can't
say the n-word in his album like so we
can't even talk about the Indian Removal
Act right exactly how to say Native
American Removal Act anyway so if I
offend you or let's just assume that we
get the wrong words here um now that
being said that being from Canada I only
learned about the evil the evils of
colonialists guys and most people who
sat down I'm gonna sit down today with
me I said that's what they've learned
here mattifies none of them were aware
of a lot of the barbaric practices from
Native Americans not a single one knew
that they hadn't domesticated horses not
a single one knew that they didn't use
the wheel um and of course right you
watch the Disney film you see well poke
connoisseur any you see them on
horseback culture right with the almost
everything that we see as a matter of
fact I think was in HuffPo where they
were saying it's time to change Columbus
state to initiatives people's day and it
showed a Native American out of course
as a bow and arrow so I see much more
infamous information going the other way
but I do think that it's important to
delineate between the fact that we were
celebrating Thanksgiving a very specific
moment in time where they feast it
together and they relied on each other
right the the natives and I'm gonna
butcher the name but the Wampanoag is
and I think it but someone else correct
me I was like womp and no but I was like
all crap of a single day but the early
uh the early settlers and the Wampanoag
they lived peacefully knows for fifty
years and I think that's a good thing
and I think it's a good thing that
Abraham Lincoln even after all of them
is deeds that were committed and I think
some of them are misunderstood it was a
good thing to try and create a unifying
holiday for people be thing
the united states and i think the danger
in what we seal and i don't think that
you're suggesting this but saying okay
yes this was a good holiday but bad
things happened afterward therefore we
need to attach this to the holiday so
it's a really bad precedent because we
would have to do it with every single
hop right so that's where i'm feeling so
like you're absolutely right that people
do connect it but i feel that the reason
that we do that is just because we're so
misinformed so i feel that what I've
been saying is that once that says like
yeah of course we had the barbaric
stuffer then like you were saying I but
I was hearing when I was over there
Harry's saying like well they did awful
stuff to each other and we basically
just subjugated and then that helped
other tribes and etc etc and it's like
and you're right but I feel that I know
if you understand you heard and I was
saying I certainly wouldn't say that we
are Western Europeans are absolutely no
right exactly but it's just like the
fact that we did these kind of things
and then when so I feel that when we
have one side that doesn't connect it at
all we just feel like we just have the
unitary like yeah we're all have friends
for 50 years both ah blah
right and then the other side it's like
they know they're absolutely 100%
connected and it's like that's just not
true but I feel that there should be
sort of like I guess a 50/50 where we
have one side that's willing to say like
well Thanksgiving is not a racist
holiday it definitely should be
something that's more based around not
say awareness but more just historical
context like yeah we did have a piece
with them but we also have to identify
what we also did to them well the other
side should say like yes we had a lot of
war with them but we also did have a
peacetime and then something like
Thanksgiving is a actually one of the
greatest times for US history in my
opinion okay I'm good so you agree on
that that specific date Thanksgiving is
a great one
yeah 1521 the reason why I feel like is
so cultural so controversial is that
there's actually no written history of
an invitation straight to the tribe as
well it is semantics because we actually
have not only written documentation we
have a list of attendees but these
settlers now yes for the same reason
that we have a basically a written
contract of the purchase I talked about
it earlier of Manhattan for 60 guilders
right
the Native Americans didn't keep records
so even though there was no official
invitation they wouldn't have been able
to sign on it anyway exactly but there
is there are plenty of records that they
were there I put this way dude
do either one of us dispute that Native
Americans feasted with those settlers I
do not dispute okay so that's quite a
semantics game but for me it would just
be like Howard up here did was an
official invitation sent out or was it
just more of like they just walked in
and they were welcome so it's just
that's what I that's what I understand
and it seems like you might know more
about the history than I do here there
were in a celebratory sort of like
warning shots using their armaments and
so what happened was it hey what's going
on and then they realized that they
actually were just celebrating exactly
and then at that point is decided to
celebrate together in fee so it wasn't
necessarily planned like a formal dinner
invite gotcha but there was concern
right they were leery obviously gone who
these new people in the New World and
then they feasted together I don't know
if you've read that about supports of it
yes so um and I do and I appreciate your
being straightforward about that because
you'll have a lot of professors who say
well there's no written invitation
therefore it didn't happen there's so
much document there's not a written on
occasion saying that they were there and
right so yeah and list of attendees more
like even though they're not but might
not be a harder person evidence it's
likely rice likely 99% what is your
ancestry yourself Lord I am half
Filipino than half way so you have to
appear on Italian to polish I know you
could go either way my guy or the
quarter black hair people think it's
Mexican all the time exactly dad looks
really black he looks really white but
sometimes really he's Mexican but the
reason I said is because let's say and I
think sometimes we over complicate
history this isn't even written decision
I think there's one of those interesting
discussions to me but I know no one else
is gonna be into this so we're just
talking about as wonderful discuss let's
say I'm trying to think let's say right
now you had some kind of a gab you let's
say we had a gathering right of course
and people came from I'm trying to think
of some kind of a tribe that maybe has
been untouched by the modern world
whatever it is let's say people came in
with very very complicated let's say
people from Dagestan Russia right and
there's nobody could pronounce their
names and they weren't able to read or
write right and we're going okay so we
had a dinner so fill I still is here
Steven is here and the guy goes in you
slide in and leave it ish and you're
like I don't I don't go sign he goes I
know how to sign and you go alright
we're gonna mark that down as one gotcha
so they had the names of the settlers
and they had a general attendance record
how many neighbors were there but let me
ask you like how would you
this is something I often think about
when I go home think about that
logically how would you mark it down if
you didn't speak their language
you couldn't pronounce their name and
they couldn't read or write for me I
would just do sort of descriptions yeah
so that's what I would rip [ __ ] in a
line number if you got a plenty of play
a paper it'd be like tall guy color hair
etc and this is a you sound like racist
but let's be honest that to the settlers
they look very similar right exactly
they were generally the same height
black so it would just be the same
descriptions like Filipinos if I go into
a Filipino restaurant right and they go
okay I want you to write down for police
sketch artist every person here and it
could just be because I'm white I would
go like all right relatively short
mathletics build exactly brown hair
darker skin and I think sometimes people
take this sort of absence of specific
evidence to than any of professors which
is really irresponsible using that as
evidence of absence that it happened and
I get preponderance of evidence it seems
like we both agree on the source um
which I appreciate but for being when I
look at absence of evidence I just like
it to leave it I wouldn't say I like to
leave it open I guess you could say
right I'd say like I would look at the
more likely cause and I would assume
that the more the most likely reason
would be the correct reason right and
untold other evidence would appear right
but when I have that absence of evidence
I just look at it is what's more likely
and I think that that happens a lot when
you look at Native American history with
their relationship thoroughly with the
early settlers I mean Mele do they not
speak the same language not only did not
communicate the same way but the way
they viewed women the way they viewed
nature the way they viewed property were
very very different absolutely and so
something too late tried to steal this
land iguana second what if they just
wanted to steal the land and they had
guns and horses these mother did steal
their land why did they pay so much and
we have records of ship folds right
being given they obviously were under
the impression that they were purchasing
this land but when you're purchasing
land from someone who doesn't understand
the concept of land purchasing and they
come back and you're like it'd be like
you buying a house maybe selling it to
you but me thinking it's a lease and
then me walking in on your house two
years from now I'm like okay I'm coming
back and you shoot me like what the hell
how did that happen with those early
relationships and unfortunately in
academia it's chalked up to genocide or
racism so that's not the problem
the reason why I would associate I
wouldn't say genocide but like mass
murder
Verena I would associate it is just
because when it became a national
holiday because when he said it at 1863
because I say if it was I don't 1700 say
if that became a natural not even
something under 1787 when we first made
ready first got the Constitution signed
say if that same day we made
Thanksgiving a national holiday makes
sense to me but the fact that it came
after the removal acts after Wounded
Knee after was huge conflicts that
resulted in just basically us being I
would say unscathed but basically
untouched well we left them and well I
would disagree with that maybe this is
something that I was doing quite a bit
of research on this so do you know how
many of the natives were actually wiped
out as far as an estimate I mean I know
it's less than what people say it's
about it's about 50% but do you know how
many of the settlers are estimated to
have been wiped out during those Wars
it's a higher about 30% very good so do
you think about it like at that point
you can look at the Indians removal back
sorry the Native American removals act
and go like well just cuz they hate them
or you can also we're gonna go hold on a
second even though it was a one-sided
war they had especially with the the
rates that they did on Detroit
break in the day yes a lot of Native
American names in Detroit sometimes
reduced my what is this you'll have like
O'Connell next to like Massapequa which
is this weird blend but I think it's
important to note that yeah a lot of
people don't realize that because
genocide I was talking with a lady here
who was a Jewish lady it was Jenna sighs
well how many SS how many Gestapo
how many Nazi officers were killed by
Jews who were in tourniquets
maybe a couple of them like accidentally
knocked over an armoire and killed them
but certainly not 30% these were wars
that went both ways and by the way so
what would your definition of mass
genocide be just machinist that would be
the proactive
effort approach setting out to eliminate
a people based on particularly I race
creator religion okay and I don't think
I happened by that definition than no it
did not see if you talk about Indian
Removal Act or Native American move I
technically wasn't elimination it was
just push and again some of that goes
back to dispute over sort of land rights
as well over simplified this idea that
we came in and just said we're pushing
you out that doesn't really you can't
reject oppose that with the idea that
we're really the first nation to create
reservations where they have particular
rights that nobody else does really
gonna have casinos are not necessarily
paying the same in taxes like that
doesn't it doesn't really kind of jive
with what people think the Indians
Removal Act was right but I think that I
think let me ask you this because I'm
curious since you're a reason person and
I think there's a productive discussion
yes sir how much of this do you think
people are telling classrooms my money I
would presuppose especially based on my
experience here that most kids learn of
the evil of colonialist settlers and
that there was this peaceful horseback
Native American culture and that we came
and conquered it and committed mass
genocide how much of that is taught
versus what we're talking about right
now would you by your estimation totally
opinion speculation yours if you're
telling more of just like because of
course not everyone is a history major
or write something related to that
subject
every time I just basic classes to get
requirements done I'd say probably about
ninety to ninety to ninety five percent
okay so when you take those history
based classes where they weren't
specific for I maybe if anyway you just
start seeing these histories I was very
fortunate as through middle school
actually I had a Texas history teacher
okay and but he is honestly his class is
the hardest class I've ever taken my
life harder than classes I'm taking now
the way do you rationalize your position
and absolutely everything teach you a
good I'm I'm liberal leaning when it
comes to this stuff I would love to see
I went I wouldn't eliminate the holiday
but I would love to see more just more
history I guess to be more so you're
more of a classical liberal you're not
you're not a shout people down or call
them you don't believe me to be a Nazi
correct
I'm joking but uh no no I appreciate it
I was very lucky because he would be
basically even our Texas sister he
started at the at the year 811 you know
how that worked his way other than he
would even talk about you know and were
you born and raised in Texas yes are
born raised in Austin actually okay so
you know what I think I think you and I
probably a very similar story and that
if you would have been raised in Canada
like you'd probably be a conservative
and maybe if I were raised in
conservative Texas I would have been
more a seasoned I do believe it
logically I would have come back to the
right just because I believe that it is
the correct side as far as you know yeah
I think that having a teacher who taught
me to think critically you were probably
steeped in deeply Southern Christian
conservative culture moreso thinking
critically my family was very much not a
Christian family very much because
especially with her being a lesbian
right it wasn't a very good connection
and then also my parents also death so
we've also oh forget it yes sir Oh me so
it was just a lot of like conflict with
both with ideas of curing and like you
were a smart guy who's not critically
and probably would it be fair to say
natural and clad sort of more contrarian
point of view I would say so if that was
me in Canada gotcha and in Canada we
don't have a conservative well in Quebec
anyway we have liberals and Hubbell
separatists and so I would sit there and
I would learn about how bad America was
so I was just being taught about how
evil the settlers were and how much more
peaceful the founding of being history
wasn't and be like well hold on a second
that's because you still have a queen on
your money they fought off the royalty
and so I do think there's a vibe front
with with intelligent people naturally
going against the grain taking the
contrarian viewpoint which for you being
raised in a more conservative Christian
area yeah I was very did you have any
being more liberal than a classical
liberal which is probably some more of a
classical conservative in that I'm not
you know like what people would call I
don't even know what they call now I all
right or whatever it is this is very
rare like I would rather have a beer
with you then probably like 90% of my
conservative friends because I think it
we'd actually learned something from
each other
Wow your name is Phil yes sir all right
Phil well thank you this is probably
going to separate not in the
Thanksgiving them because I think it was
more just more Joseph Eisen like trying
to you know that really says like I
don't know you yet so alright good nice
guy egg fell do you want to keep the
turkey out you promise you promise to
cherish it and take it with you for all
your days all right
[Music]
hey there YouTube you if you like this
installment I've changed my mind click
on one of these other installments
playing in a box it's the only way you
can find it because if you search it it
may not show up because it's
controversial and YouTube wants to them
discourage that the controversy to
change my mind playing by the rules I
just don't know what they are
subscribing to notifications